I can't even stand
the thought of a chicken in a cage.
I can't either.
I'm obsessed
with almond butter.
Have you tried it?
It's so much better
for you.
Like I didn't know peanuts
are like dangerous.
Oh, my God,
that is so sad.
look at that.
(woman)
How do you even become
a stripper?
Oh, my God, it's like,
what happened?
Something happened.
Oh, you know it.
It's like, I wish they could
draw their self-worth
from something else.
And there's other ways
to make money.
Totally, yeah.
Host at a restaurant.
I did it.
My God,
for how long?
Oh, almost a month.
Yeah,
I really got in there.
I mean, this just makes me
really appreciate
my relationship with my dad.
Oh, yes.
Our dad like loved us
too much.
My dad's picking me up
after my workout today
and we're just gonna
like walk.
That's a nice day.
I just feel like,
like as women,
just we're blessed
with so much more
than just our bodies,
that to like
not use that,
like, you guys mind if I just
stop talking for a second?
I just feel
like I might cry.
Oh, my God, it's okay.
I cried on my way here.
It's just like
hard to look at that.
Yeah, it's so sad.
So sad.
Saddest.
(man)
All right, bitches!
Welcome to
Body Pole Punk class.
Let's do it.
Get on your poles!
Faces down, asses up!
Do it!
Whores!